-Ladies and gentlemen, over the
weekend we were saddened to hear
the news that our friend
legendary journalist
Barbara Walters had passed.
She was a great friend
of the show,
and I was lucky to get to know
her over the years.
I'll share with you one story
that you might find funny.
Don't vote on it.
But, yeah, just --
[ Laughter ]
Back in the "Late Night" days, I
got the opportunity to interview
President Obama.
So as any smart talk show host
would do, I wanted to be
as prepared as possible
for this interview.
So I called three people
for help.
I called Jay Leno, Howard Stern,
and Barbara Walters.
Jay Leno gave me his advice,
which was to set the president
up with some jokes, keep the
interview funny. That was good.
Howard Stern said,
"Ask him about his sex life."
[ Laughter ]
And do they go on dates?
I mean, how do they do things
around with all the
Secret Service agents
and everyone's watching them?
I go, "It's probably
a very interesting topic,
but I can't get away
with asking that."
So I got a number for
Barbara Walters and I called it
around 4:00 p.m.
on a Sunday afternoon.
And she picks up the phone.
It's Barbara Walters' voice.
She goes, "Hello?"
I go, "Hi, Barbara.
This is Jimmy Fallon.
Thank you for taking my call."
She said, "Jimmy, I will have to
call you back.
It is Sunday and I'm about to
take my bubble bath."
[ Laughter ]
I go, "Awesome, okay."
And so I said, "Okay."
And then she called me back,
and she goes, "Okay, here's
an interesting question.
I think this could be
interesting.
He lives in the White House
with his wife,
his mother-in-law,
his two daughters.
Besides the dog, he's
the only male in the family
at the White House.
What is that like?"
And she nailed it.
That was a great question.
I used it. That was my opener.
So I wanted -- I thanked her
for that, and I thanked her
for helping me
and for the great advice.
And after that she came on
the show a bunch of times.
And I did keep asking her
if she would want to do
a bathtub interview with me
talking...
[ Laughter ]
...in a giant bathtub
with bubbles.
And it was probably until her
third appearance, she said,
"Jimmy, I'm coming on the show,
but please don't ask me again
about the bubble bath
interview."
[ Laughter ]
She was a legend in journalism
and in television
and throughout her career.
She always did it with dignity,
class, and a sense of humor.
Always very interesting,
always very charming.
I don't know what her secret
was,
but maybe it was the bubbles.
We will miss our dear friend
Barbara Walters.